اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من مدينه جنين اهلا
بكم قصف اسرائيلي مكثف على مستشفيات غزه
يخرج 20 منها عن الخدمه والدبابات
الاسرائيليه تحاصر مستشفى الرنتيسي وسط
مناشدات للهيئات الدوليه بحمايه العاملين
والنازحين فيه من جهتها اكدت هيومن رايتس
وتش انها لم تجد ما يؤكد مزاعم اسرائيل ان
مقر قياده حماس قع تحت مستشفى الشفاء
كتائب القسام تقول انها هاجمت القوات
الاسرائيليه في منطقه جحر الديك جنوب
مدينه غزه وقصفت تل ابيب وقاعده رعيم
العسكريه بينما اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي
استمرار عملياته البريه واعلن ارتفاع عدد
قتلاه منذ بدء العمليه البريه الى
38 على الصعيد السياسي الرئيس فلسطيني
يقول ان قطاع غزه جزء من دوله فلسطين وان
السلطه ستتحمل مسؤوليتها في اطار حل سياسي
شامل في وقت اكد فيه امير قطر والرئيس
المصري على الدعم الثابت للقضيه
الفلسطينيه وحقوق الفلسطينيين كما ادان
ولي العهد السعودي انتهاكات الاحتلال ودعى
الى ايقاف
الحرب وفي الضفه الغربيه قوات الاحتلال
تقتل 20 فلسطينيا معظمهم في جنين التي
اعلنت اضرابا عاما في المحافظه حدادا على
ارواح الشهداء في حين اقتحم الجيش
الاسرائيلي مخيم عسكر واعلن نادي الاسير
ان قوات الاحتلال اعتقلت اكثر من 90
فلسطينيه الى
اللقاء